China's history is one of emperors and
dynasties until it wasn't that is when
in 1911 the Chinese Revolution so the
millennia rolled Imperial way of
government completely upended and
replaced with the Republic but what
happened to the man at the top what
happened to the last emperor of China
well to start with the man was a boy
when Sun yat-sen the leader of the
Chinese Revolution put a permanent tent
to the Ching dynasty Zhang Qing Emperor
was six years old now the establishment
of a republic didn't see him dragged
outside and killed like many Emperor's
and Kings had been before him instead
the ranting Emperor proper name a single
roku he was allowed to remain inside the
forbidden palace was given a massive
yearly stipend and would retain his
titles houyi would stay in the Forbidden
City for twelve years during which he
was briefly restored as emperor in 1917
during a rebellion against the central
government his second reign lasted for
just shy of two weeks and the rebellion
was defeated and he was again removed
from power in 1924 the Republican
government decided that Puyi should go
and so evicted him from his palace and
he subsequently moved to the city of
Tianjin in the following decade puyi
attempted to bargain with the numerous
warlords throughout China which was in a
near permanent state of civil war to
support his restoration they all said no
in 1931 Japan occupied Manchuria and set
up the puppet state of Manchukuo which
had near zero international recognition
and thus needed some legitimacy
fortunately for Japan there was a former
Chinese Emperor able to take the helm
and he was happy to do so and so took up
the position of chief executive of
Manchukuo in 1932 he was appointed as
the emperor of manchu coup in 1934 but
he was simply a figurehead of the
government there and most of the
governing was done by the Japanese
military so in 1937 a small regional
conflict broke out between the Empire of
Japan and the Republic of China and Puyi
saw an opportunity here to be restored
as the Emperor of all China or though
we'd have to do without Mongolia this
time because you know communist
revolution and to keep him in line the
Japanese consistently reminded him of
his pending restoration there was one
interesting thing about this Japanese
promise it was a lie the Japanese were
working with the collaborationist
government in China to establish a
Republican puppet state and they
determined that Puyi was going to remain
in Manchuria all of this discussion was
meaningless though because Japan lost
the war and during the closing bumps the
Soviet Union conquered Manchuria and
captured puyi now he was quite worried
at this point because axis leaders had a
tendency of getting Nuremberg he wasn't
and instead he was held in Siberia
but to the Allies to spare him since the
republican government in china wanted to
shoot him as a collaborator in 1949 the
Chinese Communists won the Civil War and
as an act of good faith he was
extradited there the next year now you
think that this was only going to end
one way for Puyi but in fact Mao wanted
him extradited specifically so that he
could spare him who Yee spent 10 years
in prison and was subsequently released
as not only a regular private citizen
but also as a fully fledged communist
which for Mao was exactly what he'd
wanted you see the Russians had shot
their former emperor an axe which had
become a black mark on its regime
whereas Mao had spared the former
Chinese emperor which certainly made
Chinese communism look a lot better in
comparison the last Chinese emperor had
after his removal from power been a
puppet Emperor a prisoner a street
cleaner and an editor before he died in
1967 and with him died the last of a
2000 year old system of government I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with the special thanks
to my patreon supporters James Bazar
neck calling Castleman danny Maloney
Marvin Castle Rob Waterhouse John BJ's
Mo Aaron the white Michael Reynolds
James Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan Hong Lei Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three crates filled
to oink-oink David Silverman is he
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski
Alexei Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappelle and Anthony
Beckett